okay
this is the last um game for today if i
win it because
then i will get to 2400 again
a rare line and i have no idea
of course it looks a little bit like a
king's indian old indian mix
g3 was played to
get the square f4
it seems he wants to go for f5
yeah maybe just a normal developing move
now get to the square
yeah it looks like a normal position
i think maybe slightly better for white
because of the queen side chances i
still have
not sure if b4 is right though because
of a5
maybe it's better to play this really
slowly
try to see what
he what he intends to do
of course i don't really object to
exchanging
the bishops on h3 if he wants to
if he moves the rook away then i'll go
before
okay i think he spotted the idea to
bring the knight to f6 which is decent
of course
okay i cannot do without this move
otherwise i simply have no no real plan
in this position i think
the only other idea would have been to
play for f4 but
for this the rook is
would be a ridiculous piece
okay
strangely enough he hasn't opened the a
file
yeah i need to be a little bit cautious
here
if he swings all the pieces here
might get dangerous okay
i need to trade this
now the queen to e4
to block all attacks
yeah he covered this one i can also
attack a form
this position would be pretty okay for
black
a little bit passive but i think okay if
the a
pawns would have been exchanged you
could have done this easily
okay now that take then d5 is hanging so
i better go for the exchange of his last
active rook
a4 is gone anyway i think
the queen on e4 simply controls the
board so
not much for him to do
yeah i need to take this i don't think
he can
get any kind of attack here
rook f2 is the sort of the last idea
but it's not even an idea just need to
avoid to go
there maybe just
look over here to
push the a pawn
yeah but it's it's not an automatic wind
or something
um
bishop g5 i guess better prevent this
i can't hurt at least
um how do i make some progress here
maybe queen g4
with the idea of queen e6 and rook g4
if he if he goes queen d3 for instance
check check here and rook g4 it still
doesn't have a check
i think so check
yeah this is complete control again
but now i can play this and win the
bishop
or the queen
black resigns yeah
nice finish for today to
just get the four points to make an even
2400 rating
yeah i guess what what he really missed
to do
was to to exchange from before i don't i
don't know why he didn't
exchange here imagine just this position
without the a
pawns and it's pretty difficult to make
to make any progress right white would
still be better of course
but how to how to
put it i'll put it how to win a pawn in
this position d6 is very much
protected and um
i don't know it's maybe maybe enough for
black now he
always had to take care of the a pawn
and
this one got lost eventually